accompagner la transition écologique et
solidaire du territoire démontrer que le
changement de modèle est possible depuis
des années ses ambitions à nîmes le
département de jour en jour nous
progressons dont la mise en oeuvre de
solutions face aux dérèglements
climatiques à la perte de biodiversité à
la pression sur les ressources
naturelles et face aussi à l'opportunité
d'évoluer vers une société plus
solidaire et plus sobre et pour
insuffler cette transition sur le
territoire nous département déployons
des actions concrètes sur le terrain en
voici justement un panorama
développer notre éco exemplarité
l'environnement et la sphère de tous et
nous l'avons bien compris les
préoccupations environnementales font
partie intégrante du fonctionnement de
chacun de nos services nous avons pu en
cette première année de mise en oeuvre
du plan de transition élaboré un plan
interne de gestion et de prévention des
déchets selon une méthode innovante
mettant les agents au coeur de la
démarche une méthode qui a permis
d'établir un plan d'action pour repenser
nos actes d'achat réduire notre
production de déchets réutiliser réparé
lorsque cela est possible et recyclés en
respectant les règles du tri
aujourd'hui 100% de nos déchets verts
sont valorisés et notre matériel
informatique obsolète réparé et
réutilisées notamment dans nos collèges
c'est également tout notre parc
automobile qui évolue pour offrir des
solutions en faveur d'une mobilité
nouvelle et décarbonées pour installer
une transition dans les pratiques des
agents le département a organisé des
journées de mobilité durable en 2021 et
2022 et un premier plan de mobilité
durable interne a été réalisé il intègre
pleinement la rationalisation des
déplacements par l'usagé de la
visioconférence et la mise en oeuvre
progressive du télétravail dont une
expérimentation est en cours dans cette
démarche eco exemplaires nous avons
engagé la réalisation de notre bilan
carbone en 2021 nous nous étions fixés
comme objectif de devenir une
collectivité à énergie électrique
positive d'ici 2024 en clair notre but
est de produire plus d'énergie
nous n'en consommons diminuer notre
consommation électrique et la compenser
en produisant notre propre énergie
renouvelable pour ce faire nous avons
engagé le plan négawatt
[Musique]
convertir nos politiques publiques
la richesse de la nature et de la
biodiversité de notre île sont des
trésors de notre patrimoine que nous
avons à coeur de préserver et de
valoriser la trajectoire écologique dans
laquelle nous nous engageons doit aller
de pair avec des actions de reboisement
l'année 2021 a été une année intense de
préparation et de déploiement de
solutions concrètes en ce sens une
initiative qui complète notre engagement
pour les espaces naturels sensibles qui
fête déjà ses 30 ans en
2021 a marqué le démarrage des travaux
de reconstruction du gîte du volcan un
projet qui se veut en total respect avec
l'environnement grâce à cette opération
le département a été lauréat du trophée
de l'achat responsable dans la catégorie
commandes environnementalement
responsable cette opération est
l'exemple le plus abouti d'une politique
d'achat vertueuse promu par le schéma
départemental des achats responsables
preuve qu écologie et développement
peuvent travailler main dans la main
la feuille de route du plan agréé pays
2030 et plus récemment celle du plan bio
qui se veulent aussi concrète
qu'opérationnel se mette en oeuvre la
crise sanitaire aura par ailleurs montré
l'importance de renforcer l'autonomie
alimentaire de notre île impliquant de
développer toujours davantage nos
productions locales et de protéger notre
foncier agricole en 2021 de nombreux
appels à projets ont été lancés comme
celui en faveur de la création d'unités
de transformation agroalimentaire de la
production locale le soutien aux
initiatives de développement
d'exploitation conduite en mode agro
écologiques nous avons par ailleurs créé
notre tout premier périmètre de
protection des espaces agricoles et
naturels ce nouvel outil permet de
sanctuariser la vocation agricole des
terrains sur le long terme et favorisera
ainsi le développement de véritables
projets agricoles territorialisée dans
les collèges nous sensibilisons chaque
année les jeunes sur les thématiques de
lutte contre le gaspillage alimentaire
d'économie d'énergie de préservation de
la biodiversité pour aller plus loin
nous avons décidé de promouvoir les
produits frais et locaux dans leur
assiette
garantir la solidarité écologique
agir pour la planète est une tâche à
laquelle chacun de nous doit contribuer
la transition écologique doit être
solidaire et dans le même temps
bénéficier à tous cela implique
d'entraîner l'ensemble des réunionnais
avec nous dans une prise de conscience
des enjeux environnementaux liés à notre
mode de consommation notre société nos
pratiques la participation du
département au salon de l'écologie en
2021 a justement permis de promouvoir
les bonnes pratiques écologiques grâce
aux nombreux ateliers proposés tout en
poursuivant le dialogue initié avec les
citoyens lors de cette démarche de
construction du plan de transition
écologique
parce que nous ne pouvons rien faire
seul nous travaillons main dans la main
avec nos partenaires pour développer des
actions conjointes de transition
écologique et solidaire c'est notamment
le cas avec les communes dans le cadre
de la mise en oeuvre du pacte de
solidarité territoriale
[Musique]
ce virage écologique demande des outils
de formation innovant et efficace
permettant de former et d'informer et
d'échanger pour faire évoluer nos
pratiques cette année nous avons initié
des cafés de la transition le but
proposer un espace des changes pour
s'informer partager des idées et bâtir
une première communauté d'agents engager
la transition écologique et solidaire
est un sujet complexe et ses outils et
d'autres encore que nous devrons mettre
en place dans les mois à venir
permettront d'adapter notre stratégie
pour répondre au mieux aux attentes du
territoire éteindre la lumière terminaux
rennais favoriser les transports en
commun les vélos et surtout qu'il entend
présenter des armes ce soir on au
collège temps d'aviser pour vous même
dans nos quartiers nous fasse plier son
ensemble on bosse de paris
ce que je fais au quotidien pour la
planète c'est le tri des déchets est
important de pouvoir apprendre
futures générations vont pouvoir trier
ses déchets donc le pack jeune le bac
gris le bac vert les composent et
sensibiliser face à salé
ensemble varié nous sommes actuellement
master énergie est ce que nous voudrions
pour la planète c'est des régimes comme
son mari avant près de 5000 agents
département donc à chaque fois que cela
est possible et en utiliser la voiture
est la voiture en carburant nos patients
a de nouveau battre le déplacement le
vélo électrique le vélo le la
trottinette ce sont des modes de
déplacement tour et donc servis chaque
agent a participé donc à l'utilisation
d'un nouveau mode de déplacement doux
ensemble face aux changements
climatiques
ne restons pas immobile le département
plus que jamais s'engage aux côtés des
réunionnais
[Musique]